do you have a product management
interview coming up make sure that you
demonstrate your expertise in product
strategy besides showing that you can
successfully deliver a product from
design to development to launch it is
important to also show the interviewers
that you can think big and create the
vision and strategy for your product
there are lots of people that can go
build a feature but there are a limited
number of people that can really think
big for example what is the next
Generation product or how can I disrupt
this entire Market that sort of
strategic long-term mindset is very
valuable to employers with the right
product strategy you can jump miles
ahead of your competitors and create an
amazing positive impact for all your
customers